foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studio it's the Ramsey show where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money I am
Ramsay personality Rachel Cruz hosting
today and next to me jade
man this is a colossal event region this
is a treat I'm pumped about this me too
that we're gonna spend three hours
together America answering your calls so
everything about your money your life
your relationships your job anything and
everything Jade and I are here for you
so that'd be fun to start off this hour
Jade kind of I kind of just want to make
this like like a like a ladies theme
hour just say it I know you want to say
girl power girl that's exactly what I'm
going to say uh yeah so let's make this
kind of a ladies themed hour because
we're both here hosting this doesn't
always happen I feel like we always have
like one of the dudes in here with us
yes we're gonna just kind of take over
for this hour uh and even if you're a
guy listening you know you you probably
have a wife or a girlfriend or a mother
or a sister you can learn something
relatable that's right for what we have
to give today so uh so one of the
biggest things that I feel like recently
I have been hearing about women is pink
tax oh my gosh you've heard all about it
of course I I I'm spending my money on
it I know that's right we are living in
the pink tax World okay so those of you
that don't know what pink text is the
pink tax is a term for the extra amount
of money charged for certain products or
services that are specifically marketed
towards female consumers the general
products such as razors or deodorants
can be used by both men and women but
the items marketed towards women are
more expensive the pink tax causes women
to pay more for similar or identical
products that that dudes use and wear
and all the things yeah it's weird
because I knew it existed but it wasn't
until I read this article that I
realized how much 13 more on average yes
some of them 25 percent more and it's
like the deodorant's pretty much the
same but you put a little flower on it
and then we gotta like spend more money
because of that I mean
what does this mean I will say George
camel and I we kind of dug into the
subject uh in an upcoming episode of our
podcast normally happy hour and as I was
looking I was like man I don't think I
even took notice if I were to be honest
Jade I don't know if I really knew but
now that I know now that the uh the veil
has been lifted from my eyes I'm like oh
my gosh I look everywhere I'm like it is
it's so true I notice it on like body
wash because I'll go and like order what
I like for me and then I'll order what
Sam likes razors yes it's unbelievable
and I bet dudes razors are even better
they are honestly sometimes I would
rather use my husband's butt because
they're in that blue and silver
packaging you know I go for mine that
are in like the cute little pink heck I
like it I like the way it's packaged
what can I say so I mean I mean I guess
being taxed I guess it kind of goes
under we always talk about control what
you can control in life we can't I mean
sadly we can't I don't know how we can
control what we buy we could buy dudes
deodorant through the cheaper and save
some money so we we have control over
that yeah but I want to buy like one
product and decide that you're just both
gonna use that like we stopped buying
like lotion for him lotion for her and
we just buy one yes and then there you
go there you go I know some ladies out
there plus my husband barely uses the
lotion which let's just say that's a
problem in and of itself moisturize your
skin people everyone needs a little
solution always always I digress oh okay
so we're gonna go into the calls at this
hour it's a free call anywhere in the
country at triple eight eight two five
five two two five and first up we have
Leanne in Brooklyn hey welcome to the
show
hello what's going on
what's going on ladies
um
so I we we started the the baby steps
about a month and a half ago and we all
we owe my uncle eleven thousand dollars
in rent and you know we started paying
the credit cards but I think that this
should come first
so I said this to my husband he said ask
Dave Ramsey and
and let's find out what you guys say and
here you are because uh he's that
skeptical about it yeah for sure so how
much credit card debt do you guys have
credit cards like not like fifteen
thousand fifteen thousand okay all
together all together yeah not much we
really thought that but we had car loans
too okay and how much are those
uh 10 and 25 10 and 25 000 okay well and
how many credit cards are in that twelve
thousand dollar credit card debt I know
you said total but how many how many
separate are there I wanna there's a
bunch of some little ones there's some
little ones and one big one okay so it's
maybe four how is your uncle treating
you about that debt like what's his well
he's not talking to us oh gosh how long
has it been how long have you owed him
this money I mean the rent isn't even
that much but really we we like didn't
pay him for almost a year
why wasn't you read the book you know we
started paying him again like last month
he paid him we're budgeting for it now
it shouldn't be a problem at all from
now on
but now uh and he was he was nice to us
for a long time but just the last I
don't know how many months it's been
that he hasn't been talking to us and
specifically because everything correct
you guys are not having communication
because of the rent not because of
another issue okay no that's it okay
what's your communication been towards
him I know you said he's kind of been
ugly about it what's been your attitude
towards the debt throughout that year
that you weren't able to pay it
foreign
I can't believe how much time went by
yeah and I was always saying to my
husband I was like we have to we it's
not even that much money we have to
figure out and it was always like well
you tell me how we really were lost
until we read the book yeah for sure
um Leanne have you guys I know you're
not speaking now but has there been any
conversation from your ends with just
kind of some humility and apology and
wanting to make rights with him has
there been that conversation
I I mean I I uh I do I tell him what
we're doing now and how I do tell him he
knows I'm that I'm sorry okay he knows
that I feel bad and that I wanted us to
do things together we usually do yeah
yeah you know dinners and whatever and
sure you know my kids love him so much
and they miss him and it's
it's hard oh absolutely well when a
relationship is fractured in the middle
of money stress as well I mean that adds
on and that it is it's it's
heartbreaking absolutely it's
interesting you know if it were me you
know in every other circumstance Rachel
I'm gonna go through and work the dead
snowball and pay things off in a
situation where there's family involved
maybe there's a relationship there it
could be worth going and paying that one
first eleven thousand what would you say
to that yeah you could
um and Leanne what I would even do if
you feel comfortable with it if you guys
want to do kind of the rigid way of the
Dead snowmobile because I think for you
guys as a family your nuclear family
getting some quick wins of these like
kind of small credit card debts you know
that that she was saying getting kind of
some of those quick ones under your belt
will give you a boost of confidence and
there's even something Leanne I would
even write out all of your debts we say
to do that for that snowball smallest to
largest every credit card don't lump it
into one put do very specific credit
cards two different car payments this
eleven thousand dollar loan put uh put
payments below that of minimum payments
of what that's going to be and then how
much extra you guys can throw at the
debt and and build out this plan and
maybe if you communicate that to him and
say hey here's the time frame important
it by you know what are we in July
January so just say by August or
whatever it is we're going to start
paying on this
um and and it's going like here's our
plan here's what we're doing I think
just the communication part and showing
him actual numbers and dates absolutely
might help as well and an apology Leanne
I think too like just a humble Spirit
from you guys which I hear in you
um I think will be very helpful so I
hope that helps this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show up next
is Elizabeth and at Providence Rhode
Island hey Elizabeth welcome to the show
hello thank you so much for having me
absolutely how can we help
well about five weeks ago
um my 16 month old baby and I fled a
domestic violence situation and had to
relocate to another state and start over
um thankfully we're safe now
but there's a whole financial situation
um going on obviously my finances are in
shambles and
right now what I am trying to do as I'm
beginning to work through the baby steps
is figure out where buying a car and
saving for a home falls into that
process as I have neither yes wow how
are you doing Elizabeth I mean that's
that is that's intense I mean that's a
that's a a traumatic thing that you
you've walked through
yes it has been very intense very
stressful and a lot of things I'm
working through you know as a human yes
do you have good support around you
I do have a couple of good friends and a
couple of family members good good good
because you're you know your your health
and your safety is
is priority
um so I'm thankful to hear that
absolutely where where are you staying
now
with a friend
well good on you for getting out of that
situation absolutely that's so difficult
especially with a 16 month old baby
um you know I can't begin to imagine how
you're feeling right now but you know
you've got this whole New Horizon in
front of you and it's a whole clean new
start so you know yes there's a lot of
Hope a lot a lot of Hope do you have a
job Elizabeth are you making any money
no I'm not okay that's part of the issue
yeah
um that's okay that's okay uh do you see
that coming into play soon for you are
you applying for jobs did you have work
experience uh before
yes I do um have work experience what
I'm doing right now is I'm currently
enrolled in a course that teaches you
how to take pictures and videos for food
bloggers so I'll be a professional
photographer from home and I graduate in
April so awesome probably in May is when
I'll start to be bringing in the money
yes is there anything that you could
start doing today in order to bring in
some extra income
if I could find something from home yes
because unfortunately the friend I live
with has a lot of diseases and illnesses
and she's extremely high risk so to have
to put my baby in daycare would be
chancing my friend's safety and actual
life you know if my baby comes back with
some kind of sickness or covet God
forbid so okay I'm kind of hanging tight
on state benefits and so I have my own
income how much is that
um the state is giving me 600 a month
cash assistance and then for food 389
okay
and can you tell us a little bit about
like your debt situation
um coming out of that relationship like
what's your obligation to the debt
um tell us about that
um well I walked into that relationship
with no debt except for about 4 000 in
medical bills okay
um and I walked out of it with seventeen
thousand dollars total debt so that's
eleven thousand dollars in credit cards
five thousand medical bills two thousand
and a program I'm paying off
um
a certification program I graduated from
two years ago so some of it's his but
unfortunately it's under my name
um
so I'm the one who has to pay it you
know I think right now the name of the
game is Just survival I think that you
have like Rachel said you've come out a
really out of a very traumatic situation
and you just need some time to get your
bearings under you and for you right now
that's you get going to school it's you
um starting to have a stable income so
that you're able to move out of the
friend's house and I think that's thing
one is getting some income in whether
that's if there's anything you can do
from from home now I'd hate for you to
have to wait till April to start working
but yeah Elizabeth I would say too you
know we talked to so many people on the
show and there's so many side hustles
yeah via just your computer right that
the work from home stuff obviously is
everywhere but even if you can be a
virtual assistant for for 15 hours a
week you know you don't have to jump
into a lot but just to bring in some
level of income to save because your
next your next Big Goal yes is going to
be to find somewhere to live
um and and then the second is to have
transportation those two kind of have to
happen I would say together if you can
and the transportation could be a two
thousand dollar cost that's right it
doesn't have to be anything fancy and
even where you live finding low rent so
um look at this next step it can be it I
think it for me it would be easy
to say I'm starting a new life and
because you've been so in such an
uncomfortable insane situation to jump
into I just want to feel comfortable and
so I would say to resist Elizabeth just
those two big things your your car and
where you live that your car is not
going to be the car that you're going to
drive forever so it's not going to be
beautiful and wonderful and that's okay
for now
um and then also where you live you know
it may not be in the part of town that
is ideal for you or what whatever the
situation is but finding those expenses
to be as low as possible as you're
starting out I think will be a really
big blessing
okay so you guys would recommend that
before paying off any debt because I
know like the payments are honestly it's
very Hefty I the cash assistance coming
from the state isn't even enough to
cover that I mean if there's minimum
payments you can make I mean just
minimum pay if you're able to make
minimum payments you definitely want to
do that stay current on your on those on
the debt if you have it yeah but as far
as working a snowball or anything like
that I just don't think that you're in
that place right now I think right now
like I said you're just getting your
bearings you're working on getting your
income up
and then so that you can eventually save
up enough to find another place whether
it be an apartment or something like
that yeah Elizabeth when we do a budget
with people we always say the first four
main categories to make sure covered are
food shelter utilities and
transportation and so I kind of want to
build those four walls of your new life
before you go and start saving up for
the emergency funds and the debt
snowball and all of that um and so I
think getting that stability under you I
think even just emotionally Elizabeth is
gonna is gonna give you a breath of like
fresh air to say okay I'm starting this
life and you're going to have a new
schedule you guys are going to be in a
new Rhythm you and your and your baby uh
and then that's when you're gonna be
able to say okay I'm in that stable
place and I'm ready to freaking attack
this debt and get it out of my life
forever and you will Elizabeth like I
can hear that in your voice you've
survived yes uh again one of one of the
worst situations ever and so this debt
is going to be nothing you're going to
be able to knock it out but I would I
would get that Foundation under you
first
okay that makes sense
oh thank you for calling Elizabeth I
really do I appreciate you reaching out
and and I have is there anything else
that Jade and I can walk you through do
you have any other questions
um I I don't think so I think that
answers my question okay wonderful well
thanks again for calling
so tough but she's such a Survivor I
mean look at her it's amazing I can't
even put my to put myself in that
position of taking a 16 month old baby
out of a violent home which is the right
thing to do absolutely going with no
place to live no car no money more you
know absolutely yep and you're going
into a friend's like she is just such a
she's just such a hero right now and I
want her to hear that and Elizabeth stay
on the line Austin's gonna pick up and
we're gonna give you uh Financial Peace
University for a year and every dollar
as well uh to start budgeting and and
take and and watch those videos because
that's gonna really reinforce even from
starting from that beginning Point okay
so what what am I doing how do I start
this and so Financial Peace University
really is one of the best things to walk
you through that as well so stay on the
line and Austin will pick up and we'll
give that to you and actually awesome
throw in a Total Money Makeover book as
well because that'll be a quick read
people read that in like two days it's a
quick read but again Elizabeth's getting
that that that knowledge and getting a
community around you so I'm glad that
you have that but even here at Ramsey
we're like we consider ourselves
People's Community too so yes so having
books and podcasts and and all of that
is going to find a good church home if
you're not connected somewhere I don't
care what you believe church is great
for everybody yes get around some
Community strong women out here Rachel
for sure oh yeah Jade I mean it's a lot
of Life happening and all of you call
her all of you listeners out there
um everyone's in a different situation
different struggles different points of
celebration in life but money is always
seems to be a thread yes that runs right
through people's lives so that is why we
are here again a free call anywhere
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll be back
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show we are
doing kind of a ladies theme hour
because Jade and I are hosting the show
today so we're making some calls from
some of you ladies and gentlemen out
there listening you know you can learn
something too you probably have some a
lady in your life so hopefully uh that
this is this is all good stuff for you
as well all right we're gonna go to the
phones and Courtney is up next from
Grand Junction hey Courtney welcome to
the show
hi thank you for having me absolutely
how can we help
well my question is uh relating to
Family Planning while on the baby steps
and seeing what the advice is for
wanting to grow your family but knowing
that might mean going in debt to
increase house size to accommodate so
we're talking about needing more space
to accommodate more children
yes okay so what's your living situation
right now
well right now
um my husband and I have two young boys
we live in a two bedroom one bath house
um we oh it's a it's a pretty
um humble size house and we owe 146 000
on it still okay what's it worth uh
what's it worth well right now where
real estate is at where we are at our
home is valued at around over 300 000
with all the
um fixing up that we've done to it over
the years cool what's your income like
um my husband makes just shy of 70 000.
cool and you're staying at home with the
kiddos
yes do you guys have any debt Courtney
we do we have one besides our home we
have a car loan that we are
um trying to crush out sweet what's that
what's the amount of that
about 13. all right so not much debt uh
to speak of do you guys have any money
saved anywhere we do
um we have more we have about 4 000
saved
um I'm not comfortable going down to 1
000 save to put it towards the car loan
just how expensive everything is right
now why
oh just because I don't know if anything
were to happen it doesn't seem like a
thousand dollars would last a family of
four very long in a true emergency and
actually my family is going through a
little thing right now because my
husband had a medical incident
um and he has been off of work for a few
months which has greatly reduced our
income okay and short-term disability is
about 50 of what his normal pay is so
it's showing me how quick you know
a thousand dollars really could go if we
you know got into a tighter situation
than what we are in well let's let me
take a moment let me let me take a
moment and debunk that for a moment
because I understand where you're coming
from
um but the thing that you've got to
realize is most people have no money
saved for emergencies like if in a
thousand dollar emergency came they
would have to put it on a credit card
because they don't have any cash saved
so the point that the fact that you have
money saved is a really great thing and
you know in your situation Courtney it's
actually it's wonderful because if you
were to
keep a thousand dollars saved for baby
step one you could pay off that 13k car
note in no time now in the in the
instance where you know you have a job
loss or something like that you know
you're able to pause the baby steps and
get back on your feet but you know I do
want you to see this as a plan that can
work for you you know I know that your
husband is going through something right
now but I don't once once the Smoke
Clears on that I don't want that to keep
you from working the baby steps and
getting to where you want to be
because I agree with you I think that as
a family of four you want as much
stability as possible and I truly
believe that working through this plan
is going to get you on the most stable
footing because baby step two is going
to get you completely out of debt and
then you're going to save up three to
six months of expenses in your case six
months of expenses because it sounds
like your husband is the only one
working
and that means after that you're able to
save up for a home and you're going into
that new home purchase whether it's
selling the one you have and upgrading
you're going into that with completely
firm footing and a firm foundation does
that make sense
it does I I do hear that
yeah and I think Courtney for you the
question you know that you you asked for
growing a family
um you know I never want money to be the
thing or stuff to be the thing that
stops you from growing your family so I
would say grow your family and I know
this sounds great people probably hate
me for this but I'm like
I've I swear our kids lived in a pack
and play in a closet they don't care for
her for a good bit too so I know that
like yeah it's it's a it's a small home
um but I would not be under the
impression I understand it would be nice
to have more room for sure absolutely
and maybe you guys are at a point that
you're like you know what another baby
would stress us out so let's just wait
another two years get some get some
things under us and as a family that's
how we decide but we never tell people
not to get married or not to expand
their family because of their their
money situation I think that that is a
very personal uh decision that you guys
can make and if you want to and you are
at a point like I really want another
baby then do a quarter you guys are
gonna figure it out and you may have a
few years where it's where it's tight
you're like oh my gosh we got to pay off
that car and we're gonna save up for the
emergency fund it's gonna give you that
much more motivation you know to then
figure out the housing and say okay good
you know the house is maybe even worth a
little bit more
um and we're able to have a good down
payment you know and you and you keep it
going so this isn't a plan that's going
to take you 10 years right it's a plan
that's going to take you maybe 36 months
absolutely and so I would say Courtney
if you guys want to keep expanding a
family I would do it
um but that doesn't mean you have to you
know go take on a bigger house because
you guys just aren't I wouldn't say in a
great position to do that right this
moment I would like Jade said pay off
the debts have that good emergency fund
in place
um and then go from there and and I
think that's just going to give you a
lot less stress
I think that we could be done with baby
step three by the end of this year or
early into the next year and so at that
point
foreign
what do you say about increasing
your mortgage
so the the principle yeah totally I hear
you yeah so the principle would remain
the same you know we teach that we don't
want
um your mortgage payment to be any more
than 25 of your take-home income and
that's all things considered the
insurance the taxes All Things
Considered no more than 25 of your
take-home pain of course we want you to
get a 15-year fixed rate mortgage how
does that sound
yes I understand that yep I think that
yes
very good and I can't stress enough
Courtney because I don't think that I I
feel like you might be trying to go past
it maybe I misread that but I cannot
stress enough please please please work
these steps in order they they work I
could tell that you're like now let me
just see what if I went ahead and did it
like this I beg of you not to do this
thing I'm telling you work the steps in
order I my husband and I we try to be
too much of a rebel but it seems like if
I can foresee crushing the car loan in
the next you know within the you know
less than the year oh yeah then
um it's
it's hard like I said it's hard for me
to want to let go of a little bit of
extra savings that we have
um like I just kind of like to like set
it like just forget about it back there
just because you know if you had to put
your family up in a hotel for a week you
know like that would be more than a
thousand dollars you know and then and
not having to go in debt to do it but I
I
I'm new to hearing about the baby steps
plan and we've been listening to
um the audiobook and I'm like really
compelled and I'm really inspired and I
you know want to trust in it and Trust
Courtney trust it trust it millions of
people use this plan to get out of debt
to save up money to buy homes to become
baby steps millionaires the plan I tell
people the plan works if you work it if
you kind of do ish like Dave says all
the time ish is a wish and you'll be
wishing that you had worked the plan the
way the plan says so that's all I'm
saying I'm saying work the plan in order
you can do what you want to do but I
think that you should work the plan in
order baby step one two three three B
that's what I would do absolutely Jade
well said well said but but you know and
you know to Courtney I'm like I I
totally get what you're thinking right
if you've been in the Viewpoint of money
of the world yeah then it's like well of
course you know we'll we'll get a bigger
house and have a baby expand and keep
some money all of it right like I
understand where you're coming from
Courtney but part of this change is
feeling the change and the change is
going to be uncomfortable any change is
uncomfortable it's not easy uh but just
I would say trust the process and you
know what Courtney if you get you know
18 months into this and you hate it
you can there you go it's a free world
you can say I'm I'm going broke I'm not
doing this anymore uh but we really do
believe it leads to freedom and
stability so good luck Courtney thanks
for calling
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
our last caller
we talked through you know some things
about her wanting to expand her family
in her home and all of that but she did
mention that her husband's income was
cut in half because of a disability and
there was kind of this up in the air
situation so I think that what she had
said was that they were coming out of
that so that's why we were a little bit
gung-ho on it but that's true but for
those of you listening just now there is
a there is a storm mode quote unquote uh
time in life right so that could be if
you are
um you know expecting a baby if there's
a medical emergency if there's a big
move coming up that you know we do say
you can pause the baby steps and pile up
some cash to get through those
quote-unquote storms and then when those
past things settle you just jump right
back in yeah
um and so for her you know if that if
that medical situation was going to
continue then she should keep the four
thousand dollars sitting there that's
right that's right but it sounded like
she was coming out of it that's why Jade
and I were just honored yeah I really
wanted to make sure that she wasn't
going to go into home buying mode and
like right let's do all this stuff
without working the baby steps for sure
for sure so I wanted to clarify that but
but it's great because again that's a
question yeah and a situation that a lot
of people are in and because of the
housing market and people's emotions
around that it can be this like
wishy-washy feeling of oh my gosh our
house is you know yeah that's gone up in
value and not all of it so so great well
to finish out the last segment of ladies
theme hour we have we have Tiffany in
Vancouver hey Tiffany welcome to the
show
hi thank you so much for having me it's
really exciting absolutely how can we
help
well I'm on maternity leave right now
and I'm trying to figure out if it's a
good time to start a business for me
personally oh congratulations what what
number baby is this for you
uh baby two baby two okay awesome and
how much of maternity leave do you have
left
well it's an 18-month leave but my 12
months of money runs out in April okay
so I'll have this six month period where
no money's coming in but my job's
waiting for me and I I think it's a good
opportunity to start a business but I'm
also a little worried about expenses
what kind of business are you thinking
about starting
well I'm a therapist I'm I'm a
registered therapist and I've done some
private practice on the side for five
years but I'd like to make it a real
thing I like to have a solo practice
that I start yeah so what would keep you
from doing that I like the idea tell me
tell me the pros and cons in your mind
pros and cons for me is
um during this six months where I don't
have any money coming in
um I don't there's a little bit of a
cushion but not a ton so for example if
I don't get enough clients coming in I
really it'll take probably one month to
six weeks before I start going in the
red and that seems like a really tight
not enough cushion there really
um so that's a concern there's a little
bit of overhead not a bunch because
we're going to be a virtual therapy
practice but I have to build a website
which is about a thousand dollars and I
have a hundred dollars a month in
software that I'll have to be doing so
not a ton of overhead but a bit was this
something that you were interested in
like prior to the pregnancy or did this
just come about as an idea recently
oh no this has been long long term plan
where I thought okay I planned it out to
have this six months where I'm not at
work so that I could build my practice
but now that it's approaching in April
I'm just starting to feel a little
nervous that maybe I'm being foolish
Tiffany will you go back to your other
job will this just be a temporary thing
just to hold over and get some income in
or do you think you're going to want to
do this full time even after you know
your your job opens back up
definitely want to do this full-time
eventually I one time a caller called in
and they said you know I want to jump
out of the boat but I need to build a
Lifeboat like I want to jump on the ship
so go to my phone and that's my plan my
main job my full-time job that I'm on
leave from it's really quite stressful
and it's not somewhere I want to be
long-term okay and I do want to kind of
build up my own situation so that I can
yeah transfer into that eventually
um Tiffany are you the only one bringing
an income in your home no no my husband
has has a good paying job thankfully
okay so when you said I'm going to go
into the red
walk me through that what do you mean is
does his income not support the home or
or
what what's like the math around that
it does
um so he uh we do pretty good our
average income is about
10 11 000 a month which isn't too bad
and I've been bringing in 4 000 on my
leave per month okay okay
and then when I in April that's the four
thousand is gone and then daycare is
about a thousand we'll be I'll have to
start paying for that so that's five
thousand
you know four thousand gone and then a
thousand extra and
um and then with our expenses our
expenses are you know between nine and
ten thousand a month and then
um but that could get trimmed down I've
really noticed we have a lot of
Lifestyle
um I was gonna ask if you're on a budget
are you guys budgeting your money or is
this kind of just you pulling the
figures out of
no no I've definitely we're we're
budgeting
um the we actually paid off a hundred
thousand dollars in debt get free from
the house congratulations sweet yeah
thank you
um so that was two years ago and we paid
everything off and it was a lot of
effort and hard work and then in the
past two years I just Lifestyles crept
up and up and everyone's in gymnastics
and people's personal training and and
we go out to restaurants more than we
should and so you have that three to six
months
um it's it's light it's okay we did have
it and then it got depleted a bit so we
have 16 000 so that should be higher for
us for sure so here's what I want you to
do I really think you can tighten up
this budget and I think if you can
tighten up the budget and I think
because you knew going into this that
there was going to be that six month
period where you you weren't going to
have money and I love that you were
thinking of a way to make money during
that time so I think that you should do
it because when I'm looking at the
overhead it's not a whole lot and it
sounds like if it was something that you
were planning on getting to to begin
with is it something where you can get
as many clients as you can or work you
know slowly getting in and then if you
don't have enough to support you long
term you can do those see those clients
on the side and work your job while you
build that business up to take the place
of the full-time job
it's true I can and I I do have a
contract that someone has offered me
that I could do
um kind of short term that would that
would provide a little bit of money it's
not my full-time job it's not my private
but it could provide a little bit of
income while I'm building I guess yeah
that as well for sure yeah I think
Tiffany if you guys look and just say
okay you know for this season cutting
back yeah because I think out of this
you know nine to ten thousand dollars
you guys can cut it cut a good bit um
yes and to be able to say how much how
many clients do I need to see a month to
keep or even that could be the game
right yeah I always hate that like
cutting the lifestyle part I know it's
always and that hurts me because it's
just I hate it I'm like I just want
people to enjoy your life yeah even
though that it is a big part of the
formula but you could be able to say
Tiffany hey if I get I don't even know
I'm making it up 10 clients a month it
actually will support us and we don't
have to change a huge lifestyle change
and I can get this going
um yeah you could do both but if you had
to cut your lifestyle because there's
not enough you're are going to survive
this isn't going to be a long-term life
that you're cutting the gymnastics or
the or the personal trainer whatever it
is you can get back to that eventually
for sure but uh just know if that if it
comes down to cutting that it's for
short term but maybe you'll you can do
the math and kind of figure out okay I
can get enough clients yeah to support
and continue on our life and what what a
blessing to have that you know that 18
months and and to be able to say I get
to go after what I want so and and the
work that you do is incredible I mean
people that that help people go through
life with therapy and counseling it's a
it's a gift it's a blessing so and
people need it more than ever now yes I
know I'm excited for you Tiffany that's
great very good yeah I feel like for for
a lot of women it's a it's an
interesting uh having a baby changes a
lot right it changes your world view it
changes uh your priorities I mean all of
a sudden kind of this whole other part
of your heart and your life opens up
you're like what uh and so it's a great
practice to kind of go through so I love
that even on maternity leave she's like
looking at so a passion of her is a
therapy and being a therapist I'm
excited for seeing that that pathway
come through I'm excited for her I think
that I think if she goes after it she's
going to be surprised at what she's
going to be able to build in such a
short period of time yes and it's great
that she doesn't have to go buy a bunch
of supplies and start a business that
has a lot of overhead you know what I
mean like it's you're in a great
position I love me a low overhead
business uh amen amen well thank you
Tiffany so much uh for the call Jade
always fun hosting yes love sitting next
to you and all the guys in the booth and
thank you America for listening this is
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the Pods at
Moving and Storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I am Ramsay personality
Rachel Cruz and hosting at this hour
with Ramsay personality Jade actually
our newest Ramsay personality and so we
are here to take your calls it's a free
call anywhere in the country at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and if you're a new listener and you
guys want to know more about the baby
steps we talk about the baby steps so
much on the show and you want to get
started on those go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button from there we're able to
really figure out the next best steps
for you based on your very specific
situation where you're at so that's
really one of the best ways to get
started we have so many new listeners
through podcasts and YouTube and even
radio still and and it's it's amazing
that like it can be it can be
overwhelming right when you listen to
the show you're like oh my gosh there's
so much what do we do so really I would
encourage you new listeners out there
and even if you've been listening for a
while and you haven't really jumped into
this process go to ramseysolutions.com
and click get started
so we're going to the phones this hour
we're gonna start off with Cody and
Rochester hey Cody welcome to the show
hi guys how are you doing today we're
doing good doing well how can we help
yes I was just calling to ask and I've
never heard this question before but
when it comes to debt is it better to
pay off your Consumer Debt first or
future IRS that's first
what do you mean when you say future IRS
debts
so what I'm saying is like so I work
full-time at a hospital but I also
doordash on the side and because I have
to pay in for taxes for this upcoming
year is it better to try to save up as
much as you tend to pay off that first
or pay the Consumer Debt by the time
that taxes are due first yeah so
whenever you have a a job like that
that's 1099 or where you're responsible
for the taxes ideally you want to set
aside a portion of that money
um each month for taxes so I'm assuming
you haven't done that yet so it sounds
like you're kind of playing catch up
with that and trying to set that aside
now
yeah so I mean I know that for like
other I have a car payment as well for
for debt but like when it comes like a
couple of credit cards and consumer I
know that I can have all that paid off
by the time that I'd have to do my taxes
for those a year but I just didn't know
if it was better to save that money and
try to put that towards IRS because I
know they can charge you the extra
penalties of yourself or not paying it
on time yeah I hear you Cody so so
saving for the taxes would be priority
before paying off the debt for sure and
even for all of you listening if you
have IRS debt in your debt snowball we
say to move that up as well and pay that
off first that's actually one of the
only times we say to kind of go out of
order of the debt snowball so the IRS so
yes Cody I would use that extra money
instead of paying off consumer debts
save for your taxes so that you're not
going to be behind when it comes and
then start your debt snowball but maybe
you know and for some people the taxes
may not even be as much and maybe you
have some extra left over from the
savings that you can throw and and kind
of get started on paying off that debt
does that help yeah yeah because like I
I have like for my whole life Rachel
like I've been trying to learn
everything on my own and honestly like
I've been listening to you guys like the
last three years since I started the job
at the hospital that I've been doing so
just trying to do this on your own is
kind of difficult and I just want to
make sure I'm doing the right thing
going out down the right path for myself
and for the future absolutely Cody well
yeah you're doing it you're doing an
amazing job and so uh I know that yeah I
can kind of feel like a lonely journey
and when you're just trying to put all
the pieces together uh on your own that
yeah it can it can seem overwhelming so
I'm so glad that you called and yet but
that that is the answer make sure to
save up for that tax the taxes first
before the debt yeah because I'm not
messing with the IRS I know oh my gosh
you do not want to mess with the IRS
because they can garnish your wages they
can do so many things when you owe them
money it is not fun plus dealing with
them is exhausting pain in the you know
what yeah and speaking of taxes you know
our our protocol or what we what we
recommend to people is if you if you can
kind of get that that Z zero in a sense
where you don't owe a ton and you're not
getting a huge refund that's ideal
because I think that's another a little
bit of an emotional misconception James
absolutely as we're entering tax season
when people get a tax refund they're
like oh it feels so good free money and
it just kind of feels like oh we can go
and spend and enjoy this and it's like
this newfound money no it's your money
it's your money extra money that was
sent to Washington and so uh be be
looking and even if this is your maybe
your first uh year listening to us and
doing taxes and all of it maybe you do
get a big refund right but I want you to
to take note of that and change your
withholdings and your paycheck so that
next year that's not the case because
ideally again we don't want the
government to owe us money because
that's money that's sitting in
Washington that's not making any where
it could be invested or paying off debt
or using it as a tool absolutely and I'm
with you on that and owing money is hard
to Jade can I say that last year that
happened to us and I'm like owing money
it's the worst feeling we're like I have
to write a huge check because I know I
mean obviously I have to it's taxes but
you're like oh man yeah I feel like it's
a little easier with like small business
or in his case like 1099 just setting
aside that little bit it's pretty easy
to calculate out what what it's going to
be and if you pull that out of each
check you can pretty much end up right
pretty right yeah pretty much right on
so great all right up next we have
Jonathan in Tampa hey Jonathan welcome
to the show
hi thanks for having me absolutely how
can we help
so my wife and I are long time Dave
Ramsey followers we completed FPU in
2014 and we're getting into some fun
problems I guess if I could word him
that way yeah we're on baby steps four
five and six
um we are at a point where we we owe 120
left on the house
um so we're paying it down aggressively
if we stay on our current plan
um without adding any more additional
funds will be done uh like done done
here in May of 2026 will be our final
house wow awesome so exciting yeah yeah
we're pumped
um we have some money uh aside right now
that uh our emergency fund just kind of
keeps unexpectedly uh growing
um
we're working to zero but uh the the
zero balanced budget every month but
um I got some bigger bonuses this year
um so with this extra money uh we could
in theory pay a lump sum into fully
funding our kids college funds but I
feel so close to paying off the house
that I selfishly want to pay off the
house and I mean we still have a lot of
time with our kids they're they're six
four and 12 weeks old yeah wow what
should we do here you know I'm I'm the
one that likes to work the baby steps in
order because obvious obviously you are
doing four five and six simultaneously
so you know and it's good that you have
the money you're investing the 15 you
know you don't have to fully fund five
all at once you can still put some
towards the house I just don't want you
skipping over five to give it to the
house yeah do you have any call do you
have any savings in the colleges College
savings at all right now
yeah yeah we have a five two nine and we
live in Florida
um and and Most states I wouldn't
recommend they uh doing doing a free
play but Florida has a pretty aggressive
tuition prepaid that we we're in for our
our oldest right now yeah and I think
because of your kids ages Jonathan I
think you'd be okay to be more
aggressive towards the house because you
guys are going to have time absolutely
to save up for the for the kids college
so yeah baby step five is not fully fun
you don't have to like fully function
the kids college intentional now if they
were 17 I would probably have a
different answer for you uh but since
they're so little yeah I would say you
can be more aggressive towards the house
maybe throw a little in the 529s just to
yeah keep them going keep it going uh
but besides that yeah I think I think
you're doing great Jonathan I'm excited
for you may of 2026. we're cheering you
on this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so it's the time of year that we get
flooded with calls because everyone's
looking just have a fresh start with
their money maybe create some new habits
break old habits and especially since
it's been a it's been a tough couple of
years so if that's you you can't just
wish that things are going to change you
guys you you can't just sit there and
wish and expect things to be different
and things to and things just to happen
you're the one that has to do different
things with your money you have to have
a plan and that plan we teach in
Financial Peace University so this is
the course that will help you rethink
how you manage your money you'll learn
step by step on how to pay off debt and
build wealth and nearly 10 million
people have taken FPU and have followed
this plan and it works so when you
intentionally follow the plan with
intensity again this could be a totally
different year for you you know you
could be in a different money situation
when you look up this time next year so
start Financial Peace University right
now at Dave ramsey.com FPU that's
ramsaysolutions.com FPU
and a few Jade for you guys was was a
huge game changing point for you yeah I
tell people all the time if you don't do
anything else just get signed up I mean
it will change your life it'll change
your money it'll bring your relationship
closer if you're married yes I mean it's
just there's so many positives that you
can take away from it you know I love it
possibilities are endless people yes so
one thing Jade I feel like we we both
enjoy good social media and yes and now
that it's everywhere all the time uh
there's a lot of people giving Financial
advice out there and so we always we
always have a good chuckle it's like I
love it and I hate it but at the same
time you were saying earlier like Rachel
I keep seeing this thing so I was like
well let's talk about it Jade okay so I
mean we're in the finance space so you
know the people that you follow tend to
be in your same world even if you don't
have the exact same views it's like okay
like I follow other money people and I
gotta tell you Rachel there's somebody
that I follow and it's just so
frustrating to me because a lot of her
posts are about women having their own
finances separate from their men but
it's in a way that's a little bit
secretive right and okay don't get me
wrong if you're not married and you're
just living together or it's your
boyfriend yes keep your money separate
but if you're married I believe that you
should work together with your finances
you should combine things and I know
that this person's point of view like I
know like their background they were
hurt in a relationship and all this but
I just feel like the advice is not where
it needs to be and I as a married person
you know keeping money aside secretive I
for me that's a that's that's Towing the
line there you know that's keeping
secrets and like keeping all of your
assets in your name I mean what's the
message that that's sending the message
is I don't trust you
I don't see a I don't see your for sure
future here so I'm just gonna keep mine
over here in my pocket and my account
and you don't touch it is that really
the way the footing that you want your
relationship to be on I mean
and what's and what I think a lot of a
lot of these people I think you may have
said this earlier you know that it's
it's a lot of fear yeah it's all it's
living in a lot of fear and and again
are there situations that you want to be
smart right if there's you know you talk
to someone that came out of a domestic
abuse situation right if there's
something like that going on or an
addiction I mean there are these these
points that okay I'm gonna be smart but
overall you guys for majority of couples
yeah working together it's a it's
amazing the level of communication
that's created yes the level of trust
that happens and the just the Oneness of
marriage that you're experiencing even
with your money and the facts tell us
that I mean there's studies that say
couples who communicate openly about
money tend to feel that they're on the
same team it says quote feeling like
you're on a team together with your
partner promotes relationship
satisfaction and so I do think that
there's a way as a woman because we're
all talking about all the women things
today there is a way to feel like you
have and not to feel like it but to
actual have actually have equal footing
equals say and God forbid if something
happens you don't get left out in the
cold yes right Rachel I mean I for me
it's knowing what's going on with your
money making sure that you are combining
everything making sure that if you're
purchasing a house it's not just in his
name it's in your name too making sure
that if there's retirement accounts
you're the beneficiary on everything so
for me it's more of approaching the
money in a way that I know exactly
what's going on I'm not ignorant to the
situation I know it's going on as
opposed to I'm just gonna have my life
over here and you know what have you and
I know for me when I first got married I
was the woman that was kind of the other
end of the spectrum that was like I
don't know what's going on I don't care
he brings in the money you know and I
really thought like oh ignorance is
bliss right right ignorance is not Bliss
it is broke yes and you will end up
broke and then you won't even know how
you got broke so I can't say it enough
that the solution to the problem is not
is not going off on your own and and
being secretive with money hiding your
money having secret accounts I'm not
against having your own
piece of money out of the budget right
right like having a line I mean I have
line items Jade's Jade's fun and Jade's
yes hair and Jay's grooming that's fine
you know and I don't have to tell Sam
okay I spent 12 on shampoo right I'm not
saying that I'm not saying that you have
to be controlled but I am saying that
you should share your finances yes
absolutely because the benefits
it's beneficial right if it was harmful
all the time then we'd probably have
different advice you guys but yeah but
the benefit of what we've seen day in
and day out and even you know we quoted
10 million people have gone through
Financial Peace University right like we
work with literally millions of people
that have done this plan and it's one of
the top comments that we get that our
our marriage feels closer yes and
there's something about it you guys of
combining so if you haven't yet we we
encourage it we really do and I love
that the science backs it up too it does
have that conversation have those tough
conversations for sure well it's a free
call anywhere in the country at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
up next we have Dustin in Memphis hey
Justin welcome to the show
hey how are y'all doing today doing good
doing great how can we help
yes so uh obviously come into a good sum
of money and I'm trying to figure out
what I should do with it cool how much
a little over 300 000. would have come
where did that come from
uh I played the stock I've been playing
soccer because I was about 18 years old
and when covert hit I won it big
I love that you're talking about this as
though it's gambling because that's
exactly what it is
oh my goodness oh Dustin okay
congrats on your windfall
and congrats on winning your lottery
that's amazing so three hundred thousand
dollars can you tell me a little bit
more about your just overall income
situation do you have debt like
tell me more do you have what's your
income I'll probably have about seventy
thousand dollars left on my house I'll
probably have about twenty five thousand
dollars left in my car
and that's about it I know that other
than that the job I do
uh uh help operate and set up new
locations for us for a certain
restaurant and
I'll make about 35 000 after taxes every
year okay do you have a family
yes I have well family hasn't Just Me
Myself and or my mother and my brothers
and sisters okay okay yes that does
count as family I should have said do
you have a wife and kids amazing amazing
so you know do you have any money in
savings by the way I didn't ask that
um currently that's I pulled out of that
I pulled that out of the town's mess in
one of my Banks I've got another a
six-month emergency fund as well as ten
thousand dollars another bank that I
don't touch great job very good Dustin
you're set up extremely well
um so yeah are you so you're going to be
cashing out these stocks is that yeah
okay I'm gonna cash that before it fell
because my luck and would fall out yeah
so you know what I would do is there
there's a really three parts to what I
would do here I mean definitely you're
going to be able to pay off all your
debt and become debt free so I want you
to do that I want you to save some of it
for that six months of emergency so if
there's any more that you need to add to
that I want to do that and then I want
to make sure that you're working with
just a team of people to make sure that
you're managing this money and that
you're prepared for any taxes that you
might need to pay on this because it's a
lot of money
um and Beyond the taxes the tax have
been paid on it I'll cash this out a
year ago oh okay okay
gotcha okay and I you know I have a
question what about retirement do you
have any is there anything that you're
contributing normally to retirement at
this point
because if not I saw that just yet I'm
only 23 years old so I'm trying to
figure out what else to do next okay so
we're paying off this debt we're getting
you set up with a great accountant a
great Tax Advisor a great smart investor
and I want you to quit playing single
stocks and I want you to get invested in
good growth stock mutual funds okay from
now on you're investing 15 of your
income absolutely yep 401ks Roth IRAs
Dustin I think is right in your future
and congratulations man so young and
doing it but don't let that be a habit
because it doesn't always work out that
way okay so let's play it safe for
retirement but congratulations Dustin
well done
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by Oracle including Ramsey
Solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory HR planning budgeting and more
All in One dashboard go to netsuite.com
Ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your CFO career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our question question of the day
actually comes from Instagram right Jade
from you from your DMs yeah you know
Ashley came into my DMs and she sent me
this question I thought it would be
great so she says this she says I'm 28
years old I'm a female who has been
saving up for baby step 3B for the last
year I make 125 000 pre-tax and I have
40 000 saved up for a down payment on my
first home in addition to a six-month
emergency fund congratulations I
recently started a relationship with a
great guy six months ago and I'm very
excited for a potential future with him
he already owns a house and is debt free
aside from his mortgage here's my
scenario do I continue renting and delay
my home purchase since marriage might be
a possibility in the next few years
that's option one option two do I end my
lease and move into his home and pay
rent to help with his mortgage
I'm gonna say no to that one and then
option three or do I buy a home in 2023
like I was planning to before I met him
and just sell it and combine our
finances if we do end up getting married
in a few years I want to make a
relationally and financially Sound
Decision I appreciate your advice this
is good Rachel great I mean a great
question Ashley uh yes so from a b and c
definitely not B we don't suggest moving
in uh uh if you're not married and yeah
it gets a messy messy Finance is all of
it and relationships and all that stuff
but would you continue renting And Delay
the home purchase or go ahead and buy a
home you know here's me I'm Rachel this
is what I would do and I I base this off
of life experience that was not my own
it was my sisters she had met a guy and
she had already been planning to buy you
know buy a house but I mean it was still
early in the relationship six months I
mean six months is pretty early yeah and
so she was like this is what I planned
to do and I have the money to do it and
she bought her house and then they ended
up getting married and he ended up you
know that became their house now there's
some things to consider here that's not
like in the fine print like six months
you know that means a lot of different
things for a lot of different
relationships right and I don't know how
much she's like projecting like I don't
know where this relationship is and I'm
very much into like Do Your Own Thing
while you're your own person yeah say I
don't know that the first one is not
wrong no it's not
um yeah it's hard I mean like if you
guys actually were talking about
marriage and there was a timeline yeah
and it was like all right fall of this
year we would love to like if you know
it's coming yeah and you know it's
coming then delay it because you guys
will yeah move in but if you just love
him and you think he's great but
marriage hasn't been talked about but it
just feels like a great relationship I
would probably continue I would I would
continue to move on
um because a house ideally you keep it
for five years is kind of our rule of
thumb but listen worse comes the worst
you get married two years later maybe
you sell it and yeah you know what I
mean like it's not it's not the absolute
end of the world so it would all be
based on your relationship Ashley so
again if you guys have a timeline in
place and you're really serious and you
know it's it he's ring shot I get like
if there was a ring involved and that
would be the Tipping Point things are
moving
then I would probably pause and just say
okay let's just wait and see kind of how
this all plays out yeah uh but if that's
not the case yeah I love it Jade keep
being your own person while you're on
your own person because you never know
25 000 income 40K saved six month
emergency fund my girl Ashley is is
killing the game right killing the game
it's so good thanks Ashley for your
question and to the point that yeah
follow us on Instagram yes and DM us
because some of these questions yeah
we're able to bring here here on the
show which is always so fun to be able
to answer your questions love it live on
the show uh but also we we try to we try
to get in the DMS and talk to you guys
and answer questions so definitely
definitely reach out all right up next
we have Brad in Fayetteville hey Brad
welcome to the show
hey guys thanks so much for having me on
absolutely how can we help
hey um I had a question for you guys
um I've had this conversation my wife
but she's not quite a fan
um so we've pretty much paid off our
credit card set for one it's load
balancing around 400 on it so we'll
probably take care of that next couple
months completely but I'm really the
only that we have besides that is our
house and her student loan which I know
now is our student loan
um and it's at uh forty one thousand
dollars so basically my question is on
the house we um are paying on
um I still owe 111 000 on it and when I
look on Zillow not sure how accurate it
is but it hasn't listed like
um could sell for around one well 186
um thousand dollars so my question is do
we just stay in the house and continue
paying on it and just kind of make
payments on her didn't loan so we can
get that down to zero or should I sell
the house and use what money I make on
my house to put on their student on to
pay that off and we just rent for a
while
how's the mortgage payment in regards to
your income is it overwhelming at all or
does it is it within that 25 percent
that we recommend yes
within okay uh Brad you know we we don't
recommend that you have to sell the
house to get out of debt
um if I were you I probably wouldn't you
guys are in a great spot you know what
what how much do you make a year
um I'm right at 49 000 she's right at
about 38 000 before taxes okay so I mean
and in a perfect world you guys could
live off of her income and pay this debt
off in a year right or or get some side
hustles and get this debt knocked out
yeah a house selling a house
um
again you can do it and people do it
just to get out and they're they just
want debt free but but honestly about it
you don't need to the house isn't the
problem in this and I know you probably
wouldn't yeah I wouldn't because you
know we were talking about this on on a
show the other day Rachel and I think
this is good for you to hear Too Brad
when it when you have an asset that you
can sell to pay off the debt it's great
but there's something to be said for
working that debt snowball and if you
love the house if it's not more than
what you you know if you're if you
haven't bitten off more than what you
can chew it's expensive to sell a house
and move and do all of that when you can
just work the debt snowball and be out
of debt in a year and a half and have
three to six months starting to be saved
I like that plan okay
all right well yeah I appreciate it I
just wasn't sure
um you know we do love the house and we
do love the spot we're in and whatnot
yeah I was just trying to you know pay
it all you know get rid of that student
debt after all the interest in it and
stuff but for sure for sure no I
understand how you got there but we're
on your wife's team Brad I think this
this call yeah I'll definitely let her
know she'll be happy about that I bet I
bet awesome thanks for the call yeah
that uh that is a scenario people do
bring up a lot and listen if your house
payment is 50 of your income if you're
drowning in house payment if you're
house poor all of it then yeah your
house is not a blessing it's a curse so
get it out get it out of your life but
in a situation like Brad you know
financially mathematically it's a small
part yeah they're wise about it they
like the house they like the area
they're in and so being able just to
just work those baby steps yes because
that snowball because you mentioned it
too that there is you know when we get
people that have again an inheritance or
even our last caller that had three
hundred thousand dollars in the market
that he took out because he was playing
stocks
um and you're able to pay off debt in a
big clean sweep yes amazing we want you
guys out of debt
but there is something to be said about
the journey in the process and Jade you
can speak to that because you guys you
and Sam you you did this so well over a
long period of time but there's
something that that happens to your
character and who you are when you walk
a journey like the debt snowball and
again if you if you get handed you know
if you get inheritance and you have debt
paid off I want you out of debt quickly
but for those of you working it just
know it's doing something positive for
your life even though it feels like a
lot of sacrifice absolutely I tell
people all the time Rachel there is so
much purpose in that process and if you
can
um just buckle down and go through it
you will appreciate it you will become a
much better wife husband parent you will
have so much more confidence in what you
have the ability to do not just in money
but in life I think that something
really powerful happens when when you
set a goal even if it's a lofty goal and
you're able to accomplish it it creates
this well within you of of what you can
draw from so it's like okay I had this
debt we walked out the process we were
able to paid off and then you want to
know what the next time something
difficult comes in life that's that well
that you can go back to and go you know
what if I did that I can handle this too
and there's just I mean that's
invaluable to have in life absolutely
and so walking that yes it requires
sacrifice maybe some more time Brad you
know instead of selling the house and
using that cash to just pay it off but
the but the journey it's worth it you
guys it is worth it so well done thanks
Brad for the call this is the Ramsey
Show
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show now most
of us were glad that 2022 is over uh I
mean it just felt hard enough to keep
gas in your car and food in your fridge
money's tight and you're just wondering
oh my gosh what happened and we just
want a fresh start to the new year so
you guys you do not have to live through
another year of stress and worry that's
one of the reasons tomorrow night we are
hosting a free live stream called
Building Wealth in 2023 and we want you
to watch because we want to show you
that it you can still make progress on
your goals Building Wealth and having
peace even in a crazy economy so during
the event you're going to hear from Dave
Ramsey George Campbell Dr John zaloney
Ken Coleman and myself Rachel Cruz
and we're going to talk about how to set
goals create margins that you can build
wealth this year we're going to talk
about the market what it means to have
fear around the economy what to do about
it and so we are so excited about this
event so if you want to register for
free go to ramseysolutions.com wealth
that's ramsesolutions.com wealth and
enjoy that free live stream tomorrow
night
all right Jacob is up next in Saginaw
Michigan hey Jacob welcome to the show
hello how are you doing we are doing
well thanks for the call how can we help
uh so my wife and I are in more debt
than I ever thought I'd be in and we are
struggling with going forward with this
and wanting to grow our family
all right so tell me
um a little bit about the the debt
situation how much do you guys owe
around two hundred thousand okay what
type of dad is it
uh
175 000 of it is in student loans
okay and we have we have uh my wife's
car
and some credit card
and then some money that we owe my
wife's parents okay so how much is all
that how much is the car
uh the car is 14 500. okay credit cards
seven thousand and how much you guys owe
the in-laws
2700 2700 okay how much you guys make a
year
together 84 000 okay
and do you guys have do you guys have
kids now or you're wanting to start a
family what were you what's part of that
wanting to start a family guy how old
are you guys
we were both 27. 27 that's great
um well I want Jade to jump in here
because
um
she and her husband walked a really
powerful story but Jacob I also want to
tell you just hearing you
and your voice
um you sounds overwhelmed and tired
stressed maybe even a little embarrassed
and shameful like I just want to
encourage you that as you guys begin
this journey
your future is so bright you guys are
young you have time you have ability and
what you guys have done in the past and
even though it feels so overwhelming and
so stressful I'm just telling you doing
this job for over a decade
this can change and that's the really
beautiful thing about this Jacob is that
you guys have the ability to and so Jade
what would you what kind of
encouragement would you give Jacob as
they as they start this because it feels
like a lot I you know I Echo what Rachel
said you guys have time and this does
feel overwhelming I mean I'm not gonna
lie it's a lot of debt but it doesn't
mean it can't be cleaned up and I know
that you can get you guys can work this
plan and also you know your income's
going to go up you're 27 years old your
income's going to go up and when it
comes to the family side of things if
you're looking to start a family like
Rachel said earlier do it you know you
don't have to wait until you're debt
free you know to start a family so I
kind of want to just like give you the
the go ahead on that and when it comes
to this debt like let's just work this
out okay so are you just a listener or
have you had time to dive into the baby
steps or Total Money Makeover or have
you just learned about us through the
show here on the radio
podcast A co-worker told me about this
show in November and I've been listening
to the podcast and reading some books
that I got for Christmas okay that's a
great place to start before you get off
the call today we're going to make sure
that you and your wife get Financial
Peace University because that's going to
be what's really going to hammer home
everything that we talk about on the air
today you're not going to remember
everything yes you can go back and
listen to it but Financial Peace is
going to really go through this with you
guys and get you on the same page and
give you that hope that you need
surrounding your situation but for the
time being let me kind of just walk you
through this so that you've got some
hope when you get off the phone here
with us today so we're just going to
boil this down into the easiest possible
step easiest baby step going forward so
do you guys have any money set aside in
savings whatsoever
uh we have a thousand dollars excellent
so you got baby step one accomplished
check one very good and now after that
we're talking about paying off debt and
baby step two using the debt snowball
but before I get into that are you guys
using a budget because you're gonna need
to be on a budget in order for this to
be effective
yeah we've been working through a budget
the last month and a half or so uh-huh
are you using every dollar or just
something else
uh there's spreadsheets that I made okay
that's totally fine okay so with your
budget how much are you able to after
you've just paid minimum payments on all
of your expenses after you've crunched
everything down right because we want to
decrease lifestyle as much as possible
how much do you have to throw out your
debt
each month right now we have 1100 okay
so we're gonna just start with that 1100
and we're going to start with the
smallest possible debt um it looks like
the the family loan 2700 So you're going
to be able to knock out a good portion
of that
um you know a third of that this month
and then you're just going to keep
working down now the thing with the debt
snowball is like you're listing them
from smallest to largest I know you've
got student loans and you're probably
thinking about interest rates I know
they're on pause right now but listing
the debts from smallest lar to largest
paying minimum payments on everything
and all the extra money that you can
find you're putting at that smallest
debt now here's the thing I want you
guys working because you can only you
can only lower your expenses so much
right you got to get your income up more
too and it doesn't have to be long term
it can be temporary but we gotta get out
of debt when my husband and I were
getting out of debt we paid off 460 000
of debt Jacob and we had our regular
jobs but we were moving Heaven and Earth
to get as much money in our monthly
budget as possible I'm talking about
training dogs and selling cupcakes and
and putting tint on Windows these are
the things that we were doing to make
money and here's the thing you don't
have kids yet and while you don't have
kids that's when you can get out and
really get get your hands dirty I mean
this is this is the time of life yeah
you can be working until two and three
in the morning you don't have to worry
about a baby screaming so please please
please take advantage of this and I'm
not saying don't start a family but I'm
saying you got nine months at least
that's right that's right you know what
I'm saying so Jacob it's about hey you
know it's about how quickly you're gonna
move this needle so and we talk about
gazelle intensity Jacob and you'll hear
that in Financial Peace when when you go
through it with your wife
but there's the the the the mindset of
getting into debt is pretty easy right
you sign your name to some paper you're
kind of just falling in and it's just
you kind of we say you can wander your
way in but you cannot wander your way
out and so we talk about gazelle
intensity because in Scripture it says
if you have signed Surety my son do this
deliver yourself like a bird from the
hand of the flower and a gazelle from
the hands of the Hunter and so that
gazelle when you have that picture of
the Discovery Channel and watching a
gazelle outrun a cheetah the intensity
The Strain running for their life that's
the amount of intensity Jacob that I
want you and your wife to be in because
you're not going to knock out this debt
and it's I know it's overwhelming it
feels like a lot of you know two hundred
thousand dollars but you guys can do
this yeah you really can but it's gonna
take a it's gonna take a lifestyle that
people are gonna make fun of you you're
gonna you're not going to do anything
you're really gonna put all of your
money towards this debt you're going to
be working extra like Jade said it's
going to be a season of sacrifice but
it's just for it's for a period of time
and then after right Jade that's right
Sam you're like oh when it's all done
you're like okay look when when the
storm clouds finally part you guys are
gonna be doing a happy dance like nobody
else you live like no one else now and
that means you know an old busted car it
means selling things it means working
hard but later you're gonna be able to
live and give like no one else you're
gonna change your life you're going to
change your family tree and that change
starts today Jacob changes a choice you
can do this dude we're excited for you
Jacob so stay on the line Austin's gonna
pick up and give you a year membership
at Financial Peace University and Austin
go ahead and throw in just every dollar
as well because this was this is a great
budgeting app that you and your wife can
get on together both download the app on
your phone work from the same budget and
you guys got this Jacob and yeah and
start the family start the family so
thanks for the call Jade it's been a
great hour posting with you thanks to
all the guys in the booth and thank you
America
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions at broadcasting from the Pods
at Moving and Storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I am Ramsey personality
Rachel Cruz posting this hour with our
newest Ramsey personality Jade good to
be back with you it is good we've had a
good time Rachel I know it's been a
great a great day and so we are taking
your calls and it's a free call anywhere
in the country at triple eight eight two
five five two two five talking about
your money your relationships your jobs
everything anything and everything Jade
and I are here for you so to kick us off
this hour Maria in Orange county is up
next hey Maria welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me on absolutely
how can we help
so I wanted to ask if it would be a good
idea for my husband and I to start house
shopping this year we are 22 and 23
years old and together we make a hundred
thousand a year before taxes okay
do you have any debt
we have no debt and we have 45
000 of babies
yes very good you said 40 45 000 in
savings
yes that's good okay
um
yeah so you're newly married or how long
are you married
yes we got married uh last December so
we're one year in one year in okay you
know this is good this is this is
starting to look good so you know the
way we teach it you've walked up the
baby steps you're no debt looks like
you've got the 45 000 would you call
that like six months of expenses or
between three to six months of expenses
yes okay great so you're in prime time
to start saving for your house which we
would call baby step 3B
so I don't want you to take the 45k and
use that as your down payment because
technically that's your three to six
month emergency fund but I do want you
to start saving uh have you done any
research on what it would cost you know
for what you're looking for in your area
home-wise yeah it's expensive I was
about to say Orange County yeah and
Maria I mean after taxes your take-home
pay for you guys is what more like 60.
that's true
yes it's about 60. okay okay yeah have
you um I kind of cut you off I'm sorry
from Jade's question but have you have
you guys looked and priced anything
um where your payment your monthly
payment would be around 25 of your
take-home pay
I haven't really done the math
um but we were starting to talk to
Realtors and they asked us the same
question and then they jumped right into
okay well we can go talk to a loan
officer so yeah
how important is it for you to stay in
Orange County like are you guys open to
places that are less expensive not
necessarily you know I'm not saying that
you got to move to Montana but I'm just
saying are you open to
areas that are you know counties that
are less expensive or you know are tell
me more about that
yes we're open to moving not too far
maybe Riverside or Inland Empire
um because both of our jobs are here in
Orange County okay I mean here's the
thing you're ready to start saving for
the house but you know the rules still
apply even in Orange County even in the
most expensive counties you know we want
you on that 15-year fixed mortgage we
don't want it to be any more than 25 of
your take-home pay and the reason for
that is we want you to be able to enjoy
home ownership we don't want it to be
too much of your monthly budget you know
to where owning a home becomes more of a
burden than a blessing so I think for
you guys right now Maria it's just going
to be about researching the area and
really getting a clear beat on okay this
is what we can afford and this is what
we're going to have to pay in order to
make that happen like you're gonna have
to really get a hefty down payment for
sure you know I want you to be at 20
avoid that PMI I don't want anything
else that's going to make home ownership
any more expensive than what it needs to
be especially where you're located
okay Anne-Marie I would say too maybe
it's not a single family home maybe you
guys look at a condo or a town home or
something because you guys are still
young and maybe you want to start
building Equity right if all the math
works and it's not just a standalone you
know single family there might be other
options in the area just to build some
equity and kind of get you in the game I
think would be another another great
option but um that's a really good point
Rachel you don't have to start at the
top you can build that real estate
ladder yes yes I know and I don't want
to be Debbie down and Maria and I've not
pulled I'm not looking at the MLS if
you're of your area right now but
um it it it kind of just sucks that 60
000 doesn't go very far in California
yeah um and so I know you guys are
probably feeling that so I I really do
pray though that there's something even
in that area if there is that's amazing
or or the surrounding areas like Jade
said because you guys are in the perfect
position baby step wise financially to
purchase something just making sure that
it's not out and I've heard it said and
it's just true that you know numbers
they don't have emotions that's true we
have emotions when we look at the
numbers but the numbers are the numbers
and so really I would encourage you
Maria you and your husband to be
disciplined when looking at the numbers
because it can be very easy to say well
everyone's house payment here is Right
50 of their I mean we're in California
it's what it's what happens and don't be
in a rush you guys have got time you're
married one year right and I'm sure
there's room for your income to grow to
go up I mean do you see a trajectory
where you guys are that's right you know
earning more money in the next five you
know three five years
yeah so I just graduated from University
this past me so I just started my career
and my husband he has two years in his
career so we're just starting yeah
absolutely I hope and pretty sure it's
gonna grow yeah it will it will but um
yeah I think just I think patience Maria
but you guys have done a fantastic job
thus far I mean looking at no debts you
guys are saving you make great income
yeah that's not me saying you don't
right but you know um so you guys have
done a really great job the foundation
under you is really strong and I would
just say yeah be patient it's not don't
be in a rush you're good you have time
um but but looking at your options but
that's exciting you know home
homeownership is fun and it's something
it's like the Great American Dream right
if like it's one of those those pieces
of that puzzle that people talk about uh
but it is expensive when you own it
everything now suddenly is on you it's
true and it quickly can become very
overwhelming if you're not wise and you
know it's fascinating too like and not
in her case necessarily but just her our
lifestyles right our houses our cars the
vacations we take the clothes like
everything that funds our lifestyles day
in and day out
sometimes is the thing that prevents us
to doing what we really want I was
talking to a family and she like really
wants to quit and stay home with the
kids but their mortgage payment won't
let them and so I'm like move like
they're like there's something to the
American dream I want to shake up to be
like yes home ownership is great we want
everyone to own a home it's smart all
the things yeah but it's also not the
it's not the end-all be-all either
definitely not I think that's again back
to the social media I think sometimes
social media and like just everything
puts out there a picture of this is what
you should have and these are the things
that should make you happy but that's
not necessarily if that's not your
priority then that's not what's going to
make you happy yes of having a giant
house you know is not your priority but
staying home with your kids are you've
got to shift towards what's really going
to make it a life that you love I know
that's right and it's not worth the
stress either right so that's one reason
we're so such ticklers on that formula
about buying a home is it's not worth
the stress you guys it's not and so at
the end of the day be wise be smart but
Maria I know you guys have a bright
future ahead of you you guys have been
so diligent so smart so we are excited
for you this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to the Ramsey
Show listen if you are enjoying the show
if if you love it if it's part of your
Rhythm share it with your friends will
you uh that's one of the best ways to
spread the word because our jobs day in
and day out yes is to come here in front
of a microphone and talk about this
stuff but but truly we want to see this
this level of revolution in America
today we want people to get control of
their money for maybe the first time
ever and be free from debt have that
control and it's just it's an amazing
feeling when money doesn't have to be a
stress point so that's our that that's
our hope for everyone out there and so
if you enjoy if you're watching on
YouTube or the podcast or the radio
please share it with your family with
your friends because we want to get the
word out to be able to continue to help
people truly live like no one else and
later they can live and give like no one
else
so on the show Jade we uh we love to do
some like reaction videos right on Tick
Tock Instagram there's always some fun
money uh videos out there that we see
and sometimes I'm not gonna lie
sometimes before the show we're like oh
I'll do a quick watch or one of us sees
it and finds it before the show to play
it but this clip James came in during
the break and we have not seen I'm
scared and he's like I really want you
to see this clip live on the show what
we might find we said okay we are brave
courageous women Jade we can do this but
uh so we just heard it's about car loans
so that's all we know all right James
play the video
sir what is your car payment
uh mine is 13.25 and what kind of
vehicle is that it's a 22 Ford Raptor
okay you have another payment I do
actually my wife's hers is a thousand
it's a 22 Ford Expeditions
hey ma'am what is your car payment
13.86 and what kind of car requires a
1386 dollar payment a 2022 Grand
Wagoneer series three Hey sir what is
your car payment I got a couple of them
but the first one's 1445 yes what kind
of car is that that's a new GMC Sierra
2500 Denali
yes
[Music]
oh
my gosh okay so the video is
with a phone going through and it looks
like an office I don't even know where
they are asking different people what
their car payments are so they're there
on video it's a car dealership oh it's a
car dealership it's the people that work
at the dealership these are their cars
James y'all I can't speak Rachel I'm
talking about holy crap I can I say that
when I use an example when I just use an
example of a car payment on the show and
I'm like yeah you know a 500 car payment
like well yeah that feels big we're
talking we're talking in the thousands I
was prepared to talk about the average
car payment which is like 717. I was
prepared to yell at people for 717. my
my guy has a 1400
1400 for car one for one car one car for
one car oh Lord so that's what's crazy
is oh
I'm sorry Rachel I'm sorry
give it some Vibes James you got this oh
my gosh oh my God Rachel go Jay just go
what is what is happening go oh people
aren't dumb
this is
the stupidest thing I've ever heard I
got Rachel you are so kind and you need
to pray for me right now because this is
this is I've lost my words it's the
dumbest thing I've ever heard 13 14 1200
on cars on one vehicle you are stealing
you are robbing from your future you're
robbing you're robbing yourself I said
it I said it before the break I said
Rachel the car payment that is the thing
that is the gap that keeps the middle
class from becoming and Building Wealth
because if you invested that car payment
what it would be oh what it would be if
I I was prepared like I said I was
prepared to talk about the average car
payment 717 dollars right for one person
and if you invested that money just over
30 years at a you know 10 rate that's
over 1.4 million dollars yep 1.4 million
and then I thought okay because the
little article that we had here was
talking about how you know people are
paying shelling out more than a thousand
dollars a month on their cars and I'm
like okay well a thousand dollars
invested for that same term over two
million dollars two million dollars that
you can have two million dollars and I
just I hear we hear all the time Rachel
people well you know today in today's
economy it's impossible to get a million
dollars it's impossible to get ahead the
way my bank account is set up no the way
your bank account is set up is with you
spending all that you own a stupid
person spends all that they get that's a
that's a paraphrase from what the Bible
says a foolish man spends everything he
gets
y'all are spending everything you get on
a car note for what for it to be report
in a cart in a parking lot outside in
the rain while you're inside heating up
your Lean Cuisine in the microwave
you're not even getting to drive it
because you're working all day what
Rachel tell me to go away because I'm
not telling you anything I need to go
under the desk right now no you don't no
you don't no because Carrie here's the
deal it's the truth and what and what's
hard is that we here day in and day out
the struggle that people are in yes and
the problem is for for a lot of people
I'm not gonna blame this on everyone but
for a lot of people it is the amount of
debt that they carry yes so then you
narrow it down to a car loan which in my
opinion I told you this at the break I'm
like it is it's the hardest it's the
hardest piece of debt for me to justify
in my head because people can say a
student loan my degree is going to give
me a job or this or whatever but a car
but a but a car loan is an asset that
goes down in value goes down and it's a
thing that just gets you from point A to
point B and you don't have to have it
right you don't have to have this like
luxurious thing and then on top of that
yeah going into debt having that payment
where you could be wise and thinking
about future self and investing that
instead and still having a great car
like I'm not talking about you have to
drive the whole time you still have a
great car but you actually save up and
pay for you own it there's a sense of
ownership that other people don't own
your future sure and own your life
that's right and there there is
something about that car payment the car
loan that whole that whole debt it is a
mindset shift and when you said it keeps
the middle class it does there look we
know and I'm sure the stat I mean it's
the stat is changing all the time but
the last time I wrote it down 61 of
people living to paycheck to paycheck I
think I saw one recently that said like
73 people a percent of people living
paycheck to paycheck and I I I did the
math on this I looked at a couple of
stats and it said 43 of people have some
sort of car loan like car loans through
the bank and then of the other 25 of
people have leases not like you know the
typical loan so if you add that number
up Rachel that is suspiciously close to
the 61 percent that are living paycheck
to paycheck and y'all are wondering why
you don't have any money out here
and the magic of the of the 1100 that's
back of margin in your budget month a
month if you didn't have that payment
that that paycheck to paycheck stat
would be totally different it'd be
totally different the paycheck the the
car note Rachel is keeping American
people living paycheck to paycheck it is
keeping you broke now we've yelled and
we have given myself high blood pressure
and all of the things my armpits are
sweating I love a jade race it's my
favorite let's talk about what you can
do instead let's talk I mean you guys
know y'all know my story can I please
just tell you guys especially and I have
to mention this because culture now is
very work from home work from home
culture 2020 did that Sam and I sold our
second vehicle back in what was it Sam
2010 and we were in one car family from
2010 until basically four months ago
one car if we did it and can I tell you
the amount of money we saved for two
kids yes so what does that look like
Jade like like walk people through
because people are hearing you and
they're thinking no because my you know
my I I need a car just to get like I
grew up as a one-car family yeah and so
it's all like what you said earlier it's
formatting your brain to go what do I
value what what do the world tells us we
need two cars and they need to be brand
new cars and but what do you value I
value being debt free my husband valued
being debt free and for us at the time
we had a Hummer an H3 Hummer and the
payment was like 457 dollars a month we
had a Jeep Liberty it was 303 a month we
sold the Hummer we were upside down on
it so we had to take out a small loan
for like two or three thousand dollars
but it freed up over 25 000 of debt for
us you know so we did that and we worked
on one car we paid off that one car and
do you know what we have now Rachel
money Jenny and a paid off car and then
we bought our next car we took those
payments added them up but pay for our
next car in cash and that's how you do
it folks that's it
not much more to say Jade well done well
done this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we talk about wills a lot on this show
because everyone needs one okay it's a
basic adult responsibility and there's
just no good excuse not to have a will
we also recommend an online will because
it's fast it's cost effective and it's
just a great way to get you taken care
of if you don't have a will right now
but there are a lot of questions asking
okay is a simple will online is that for
everyone you know what if you need a
trust what kind of powers of attorney do
you need or a mirror will right there's
some specifics in there so if you have
some of those questions our team
actually built a quiz to help you find
the right options for you you'll get a
custom you'll get custom results based
on basic info like if you're married or
single where you live even the size of
your estate and then you'll be able to
understand exactly your specific
situation and we'll be able to help you
decide okay what's the next best step
for you when it comes to getting a will
so take the quiz online again to kind of
figure out what kind of will you need to
protect you and your family's wishes so
visit
ramseysolutions.com
willsquiz ramsesolutions.com Wills quiz
and take that and check it out and see
what your result is because again
everybody needs a will all right up next
is Debbie in Las Vegas hey Debbie
welcome to the show
hi Rachel hi Jade thanks for taking my
call absolutely how can we help
well my husband's going to be retiring
at the end of this month
um we've been following Dave Ramsey for
26 years and done very well but now I'm
concerned um just we're going to keep
his 401ks and IRAs in a very
conservative portfolio but mine is
pretty aggressive and I'm wondering if I
should stay aggressive
um we're 10 years difference in age okay
so how old are you
I'm 57 57 okay at what age are you
thinking about retiring good question if
it was my choice would be now but I'm
going to continue working for the health
insurance and so forth so I'm hoping
about 62 I'll be retiring okay
perfect well
um what and what kind of funds are you
in like aggressive growth funds do you
know the specifics the categories
specifically that yours are in you said
aggressive but
yeah I've kept a bit in cash my husband
is a little leery of the stock market
um he's seen it go up and down so much
and he he has anxiety about it so we
have a large amount in cash but I have
about 150 in cash and then the rest of
my portfolio which my funds are about
650 000.
um I have it split 25 with growth growth
and income aggressive growth and
international okay oh perfect that's
great that's exactly what we teach uh so
how much does so you said your cash and
what you have in Investments what does
he have I'm curious
he has about a million dollars in his
401ks and IRAs wow amazing so you guys
are you you guys are everyday
millionaires Debbie you've done that
well we are that's why we follow Dave's
and he's you know it's 26 years of
following his Debbie what's making you
say that yours are you said that well my
investments are very aggressive what's
making you say that because you've got
the perfect split you know you've got to
invested exactly the way we would say it
is
yeah I'm just worried that you know
given a shorter um time frame where I'm
looking at 62 years should I start going
back you know winding that down a little
bit and I I would like to keep money in
our portfolio um to give to our kids we
do have six children
um and seven grand babies that I'd like
to you know read something for them so I
don't want to I'm hoping not to be able
not to have to touch the 401K so I guess
in that sense I think maybe I could stay
aggressive yes yeah especially if you
guys I mean so you said he has a million
dollars in his 401k and is he gonna be
taking money out I know you said he's
leery of the stock market is he planning
on taking that all out when he retires
next month what's his plan with that
million dollars no actually he's got a
couple pensions so we uh we also have a
fully paid for house oh that's wonderful
I paid for cars um and then we set aside
knowing that he was going to be retiring
we have a little over two hundred
thousand dollars in a um High uh you
know the uh savings account that we hope
to you know if we need to draw out
during because he's not going to draw a
social security until age 70. so okay
wow we were hoping that that that
savings could Bridge us to that this is
how it's done Rachel this Debbie you
guys are killing it Well Done Debbie
yeah so for your situation like you said
you're not even probably gonna have to
touch your 401k even his Investments I
mean like you guys are at a place that
yeah even though he's entering
retirement I especially wouldn't take
anything out now I mean if if you guys
had run the numbers and you're like we
you know you want to start tape with
withdraw withdrawing to retire and all
of that they don't need it but at this
point I think you're good Debbie so I
would recommend still staying in it
we're talking about this actually with
our Building Wealth event tomorrow night
um and looking at the market and we did
um a lot of the content Debbie for that
tomorrow night for me specifically is
looking at these graphs of the S P 500
over even the last 50 75 years and you
watch it go up and down but when you
spit when you when you have the
perspective and span out you know you
you really do see that you're directory
though it's an it's an upward tick like
yeah it goes up and down in times and
we're kind of in a down but I might be
Pollyanna but I might believe in the
American economy enough to know like
we're going to come back from this right
like track record Rachel yes and so when
you look back on the pattern of that
Debbie that's what gives me confidence
even though the conspiracy theorists to
me kind of my mind can go that way
sometimes but don't say that because her
husband's gonna have my logical brain
would say to look at the pattern of
what's happened Debbie so I think you're
good and you guys are not in a rushed
position to take the money out like I
would just continue what you're doing
and I'm telling you Debbie in five years
we're gonna be having a different
conversation a man I'm so proud of you
guys I'm looking at you guys going this
is this is living like no one else right
here very good okay Debbie real quick
before I let you go people are listening
now that are possibly new listeners
they're starting this journey they're in
their 20s and they're thinking oh my
gosh is this worth it you're on kind of
the other side Debbie right you're uh
you guys have done this you've done the
work for over 20 years it's a it's a
marathon it's not a Sprint
what uh what does piece of advice or
encouragement do can you give our
listeners for for working this journey
because you guys have done it and you've
won yes
yeah well let me tell you when we got
married 26 years ago um he brought three
children into the family I brought tree
so it was a split family so we knew we
had odds against us for making that
marriage work but we were determined to
do it my husband looked at me right
after got married we've been married
maybe three six months and he says Hey I
want to try this I've listened to Dave
Ramsey I want to try this envelope
system I looked at him and I said uh-uh
I'm not doing that and he says give me
three months so we sat down got the
envelopes wrote on the front of every
one of them and we've never looked back
every dollar has a name I keep the
budget up every month we review it every
month we've never fought over finances
and that's just been you know such a
great situation and we're teaching that
with our kids as well they they still
have that little wild hair where they
want to go out and buy the new car and
we're like no no no no no
so uh you know we have to let them
stumble a little bit oh for sure yes
well that's amazing Debbie you've done
that amazing amazing work well you guys
have have done exactly what you need to
do and the results are there so yeah to
to answer the question why you called we
would say is just stay where you are
keep going especially since you guys
don't necessarily even have to you know
withdraw from your 401ks right now even
so so you're doing great Debbie just
keep at it uh even though it's a little
bit scary right now right here the news
and people on Facebook all freaking out
about what's going on
um but just stay the course the only
person on the roller coaster that gets
hurt is the one that jumps off that's
right you haven't lost any money until
you cash it out that's right amen Jade
amen but yeah he steps millionaires
Rachel I love that that was encouraging
to me I have to just say because you
know we're in the marathon right now yes
that's right and I love those calls
because it's just reaffirming that we
know this works we know that if you stay
the course like you said if you keep
your shoes laced up and you keep keep
running the marathon that's you end up
like Debbie and her husband that's right
you end up saying seeing that finish
line and that's what's amazing and I
think it's so easy to get distracted in
the world today right there's like shiny
things here or exciting things there do
this this and even though it sounds
boring and it's like what that there's
nothing exciting about your 401k and
your Roth IRA is that it but I'm telling
you it just that diligence yeah year in
and year out over time I always tell
myself I'm like okay yeah 60 year old
Rachel is going to be so thankful yeah
your future yeah the 30s in my 30s that
we that you continue it because it's
just the payoff is there and even though
there's some down years you guys
continue the race continue the race
thanks Debbie for the call we'll be back
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
Proverbs 5 20 and 21 walk with the wise
and become wise for a companion of fools
suffers harm
every generation laughs at the old
Fashions but follows religiously the new
Henry David Thoreau I like that man
that's like what George says that's some
good stuff George came yeah like when he
says if you if you follow the trends you
fall for the traps yeah I feel like
that's all right George you're a
you're a thespian that's right we were
just talking about how people are like
oh 401ks and brother they're boring they
laugh yeah those old-fashioned Jades but
man man it works it works for a reason
well I am a personality Rachel Ramsey
personal Rachel Cruz hosting uh this
hour with our newest Ramsey personality
Jade and we are taking your calls
America at triple eight eight two five
five two two five all right up next we
have a joy in Watertown hey Joy welcome
to the show
Hi how are you ladies we are doing well
how can we help very neat all right so
um before I ask my question I'll just
give you a little context but uh my
husband and I we are on baby step two
um he is in the Army active duty so I
stay home with their children and I
homeschool them and just recently we
have found out that we're expecting our
third and that's great news
congratulations yes thank you thank you
but the struggle has best been there is
this first trimester has not been easy
for me and I'm afraid that it may mess
with like our food budget because it it
tells us me wanting to like not cook
from fatigue and
um I figured it'd be perfect to call you
ladies because I know you both are
mothers um and I really want to honor
our budget and get out of the student
loan that we're in but how do I do that
when like all I want to do is go to
Buffalo Wild Wings every day girl I feel
you I feel you you go you know go ahead
Rachel well number one thank you for
your husband and his service and your
service as well joy um being a being a
spouse here
um while your husband is deployed so
um
man okay how far along are you
um so we found out a few weeks ago so
I'm eight weeks okay I'm in like the
sick of the morning sickness and all of
the fun stuff yes so I mean
realistically if I can go back to my
pregnancy days you know you may have
about two more months yeah of this of
this exhaustion so I would be okay joy
for two months just knowing your reality
because part of the budget
is is the reality of your life right
like we tell people like don't go and
try to budget 75 for food you're never
gonna hit that like that's stupid to
even try to do that so so if you're in a
position especially if and he's deployed
right now right is that what you said
no he's not the point he's active duty
although he will be soon okay okay in
this first trimester he won't he's here
okay that's good that's good so I was
gonna give you even more grace if he
wanted to be like I get it like oh my
gosh you can imagine
um so yeah so I would say as much as you
guys can plan the food because the food
budget is always the thing that that
gets people it does and again I want you
to speak in because Jade does so much of
this stuff especially on Instagram which
is amazing but um but just hear me say
Joy if if it's two months of adding in a
little bit more because you just know
the situation but it's gonna stop after
two months right like you see that end
point
um I would give you some Grace in that
for sure but also I think there's a way
that you don't necessarily have to do
that and you can plan and have a meal
plan and and do some things that are
easy cooking uh that can still stay
within the budget I agree you know I'm
with Rachel I mean the fact is sometimes
like mamas want what mamas want and
sometimes you just you know you're
you're you find yourself off at Dairy
Queen you know at 10 p.m but you know I
do think there's some things that you
can do practically that don't involve
you you know paying that premium of
going to a restaurant and I think it at
the grocery store as much as you can and
I normally wouldn't recommend this but
as much as you can buy like pre-packaged
thing like if you know your thing is
wings like buy a pre-packaged bag of
wings that all you have to do is like
throw them on the sheet pan yeah put
them in the oven or put them in the air
fryer and as much as you can pre like on
that one day you know that those few
hours that you're feeling good as much
as you can meal prep a couple of things
so if it's like all right I'm gonna like
make this ground beef right now and I'm
just gonna put it in things so that when
I'm hungry I can quickly put it on some
tortilla chips and eat some nachos you
know what I'm saying I'm not saying you
have to eat chicken and broccoli but if
you have those pregnancy cravings that
you can quickly open up the fridge it's
already sitting there in a tupperware
it's frozen you made your chili the
night before you know you've got your
chili Frozen you got your wings that are
in there you've you know whatever those
favorites are that you have you've got
an apple pie and you know in the Deep
Freeze that as much as you can do those
things you keep your own ice cream at
the house so you don't have to go to
Dairy Queen yeah that makes a big
difference it really does and let me say
this Joy someone said this to me years
ago as a mom and it was such like it
seemed like such simple advice but it
was so freeing for me so all the moms
out there she was like every dinner does
not have to be this beautiful gourmet
dinner sometimes it's just sandwiches
like sometimes it's peanut butter and
jelly and refrigerator and we're going
so so I also want to give you permission
don't feel bad because I think moms can
take on that level of responsibility of
like okay we need to eat healthy we need
to eat organic it needs to be gluten
free and everyone needs to be homemade
and it's like all this stuff and sure
there's a place for that right um but
overall too like it's okay it's okay
that some nights it's like listen we're
doing cereal we're doing eggs and bacon
and breakfast for dinner but it's like
things don't have to be you know you
don't have to have this perfect spread
every night
a lot of Grace a lot of Grace Joy a lot
of Grace keep it simple keep it simple
that's what I it's one of my meal
planning things I'll tell you this real
quick I always tell people I'm like if
you're trying a meal plan cook for cook
for no more that's what I say I cook
four things and then I double the recipe
and I freeze it and that way I'm good
not only for that week but I'm good for
the next week because I've got you know
we're you know weeks to come because
there's stuff in the freezer and then
when it comes to recipes keep it simple
I mean I'm talking like two three
ingredients sometimes yeah three four
you know there's nothing wrong with you
know getting a a piece of French bread
from the bakery and putting some sauce
on it and some cheese and making a
French bread pizza for dinner I like
Rachel's thing of peanut butter and
jelly if somebody gave me a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich tonight I
would be a happy I would go to sleep a
happy woman that's right
I know but it's it's it is so funny that
I you you or I did I I felt that and I
remember talking to a French like I was
doing sandwiches for dinner I was like
oh wait that's an option yes like on on
a hard day like that's an option yes and
it's good so free yourself from that for
yourself and uh and good luck and I pray
yeah all health and stuff for the baby
and delivery and pregnancy and all the
things yes for that third
um that's so great but yeah but food it
is it's the number one budget Buster
it's the place that we tell a lot of
people even to cut with restaurants
um and you've done so much Jade on
especially Instagram about figuring out
hey what are healthy you know good
healthy meals yes but also quick and
easy quick and easy all of it so yeah
you know from for me it's all about
being realistic because if you don't
like to cook then don't plan on cooking
like this elaborate meal like choose
recipes it's like okay I will actually
put in the work to do this this is
something that we'll actually eat you
know I think so much of it is being
realistic and from my point of view it's
about for this season in my life because
that's another part of it picking things
that I can pre-cook keep them in the
freezer pull them out when it's ready
because your girl is not trying to cook
when she gets home like literally this
whole week has been about me grabbing
whatever was in the freezer the night
before putting it in the fridge so when
I get home all I have to do is dump it
in the pan heat it up put the rice I
pre-cook rice I do so many portions of
rice and do them ahead of time so many
portions of quinoa and do them ahead of
time I you know pre-cut and and steam
the the different vegetables ahead of
time and they're already they're ready
to go yes and it really takes the
guessing out of it for me it's like the
other night we were coming home and I
thought oh we could stop at Chick-fil-A
I could pick up salads and I was like I
already have I already have food already
and it's things that I that we like so
it kind of just simplifies it and you
know it makes life a lot easier and I
gotta say a lot healthier because that's
right that's right and the saving money
on that side like I think it was I think
it was George that had a video about the
average meal when you cook at home yes
what it is versus out to eat and you
know you just look at the numbers you
look at the stats and you're like man it
is it is so expensive and for a family
of five like when we go out I'm like
even to Chick-fil-A it's painful I'm
like this is like this is crazy I mean
it just it feels if it because it is
it's so much yeah it is so much so if
you spend 50 at Chick-fil-A if you're
nice 70 if you're not careful easily
like it's it's wild so all of you on the
Journey of getting out of debt that
we're cutting the restaurants eating at
home is a great jump start to freeing up
some margin in your budget Jade great
hour so fun love hosting with you thank
you to all the gentlemen there in the
booth and thank you America for
listening this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
foreign
[Music]